The one that,
that brings the light,
the one that takes away the darkness,
darkness in this case means ignorance.
And the primary,
the principal ignorances thinking that
you are the name and forum thinking you
are,
your personality,
um,
when that is removed by the Goo remover,
which is the guru,
uh,
when the crustiness has taken away or
broken down than a,
this enlightenment that was always there
is allowed to come out.
And the guru is the one that facilitates
this.
The group who is also the connection to
the lineage teachings which extend back
in time.
We don't know how far but have been
passed to us from teacher to student
over time and,
and the guru or the bottom part is the
Sanskrit word.
The lineage of teachers is that unbroken
chain of transference.